working with ryan gosling over here to
catch a bit of the canadian accent uh
yeah a little bit I mean she's working
hard to overcome it we put him into
classes to try and teach him how to talk
like an American it's only marginally
successful what do you mean I want to
ask you some questions yeah it's hard to
see on a film full of Canadians on
partner yeah he was outnumbered well
Ryan was a bit preoccupied on set for
starters he had to prep for some pretty
intense action we get slammed through a
wall by Dave Bautista what does that
like you know he made it as pleasant as
he possibly could but it was an honor I
mean if you have to get turned by a wall
get thrown through a wall you wanted to
be David usually following up a cult
classic like Blade Runner is not an easy
feat but director Dan evil move has
plenty of respect for the original 1982
version and its iconic star there's a
Ford an absolute legend what's like
working with him on set I have to break
the ice before the set because for me
I'm not someone that is the starstruck
I love actors I deeply love actors I
love do it like but to work with
arason was different and because it's
part it slightly like in a religion you
know you when you meet your eros you
have always big expectations but he went
above and Harrisons hoping it shows in
the final product it was a we've worked
hard to get the right script and we have
great director great cinematographer
Ryan Gosling I mean to say it was but
delight